you recently lost your dog yeah I was
sorry to hear that yeah I was gonna make
a joke and it was this I didn't lose him
he died is it still funny well your
delivery was spot-on
you showed a lot of confidence in the
joke and I think that's what made it
work kill a joke I like to really kill
it yeah yeah yeah I did my dog died he
died I tried nicer about no he's dead
he's super dead he's so dead
we had him cremated and we filled out
paperwork and then they asked if I
wanted that ashes shipped to me and the
last dog that died I went and picked up
the ashes which was super sad so this
time I was like yeah just ship it to my
mailbox and so I got the phone call from
my mailbox they like you have a package
and I was like okay great I was going to
spinning class and I like walk to my
spinning class and I spun and I was
sweaty and I went in to pick up my
package and it was it was nacho that was
his name and it says like pet remains
cremated Pet remains and that's so sad
but I was also really busy that day and
and I was really hungry and so I'm like
walking down the street like sweating
crying because I'm carrying a guest
nacho yeah I'm hoping nacho and and I
walked by Chipotle and I'm like so sad
but I'm also so hungry and I had so many
errands to run I felt like a terrible
person but you know I was like I eat my
pain and all my feelings you're hungry
yeah I got my usual order my black bean
burrito bowl but like I'm crying I'm
sweating I have pet remains I set them
on the counter and like digging through
my purse to get my wallet and I'm paying
and like no one said anything yeah and I
think you you took a picture this is a
haunting photo it says so much there's
your sneakers or so I mean this is the
cycle of life everybody is like get
through the day you know I know I took
that picture and I texted it to my best
friend and I'm like this is my day in a
nutshell
you